We take a brief moment to ignore Halloween.
Because Metal Gear!
Of course I must play the new online mode for the first time with all of you.
Yeah, I hope we can play together.
Welcome, everybody.
No, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, stop it, stop it.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, I'm just going to start the game so that we can...
Unfortunately, we don't have...
Where will it be at?
Now that I think about it.
Extras?
Extras, extras, read all about it.
Wait, where will it be?
Curious.
Wait, where will it be at?
I told my DM I'd be late for game session, but I didn't tell him that it would be for tactical mid-action.
And as you guys can see, I have a little countdown time.
right here um fox hunt mode is not out yet uh it is supposed to be released in 53 minutes from now so um so yeah uh just a little bit of a little bit of a wait but i figured i was like maybe i'll start stream exactly when it starts but then i was like but what if i just want to like sit here and be like yeah we'll have to update the game most likely I'll be like,
what if I was to say that to you guys right now?
So that's why.
Boss, I have a final update about that promotion I applied for.
So the day after my interview, I got a call from the hiring HR director, and I got the job!
Thank you to you and all the whispers for the well-wishes, Solidus, God!
Congratulations!
Yay!
Yeah.
I know you'd be able to do it.
You got the job.
Solidus Scott.
That's my president.
Oh, let me, sorry, when I click out of the game, it gets rid of the music.
So...
Did you watch the demonstrations of the Fox Hunt modes from TGS?
I'm going in 100% blind.
Well, not 100%.
But I'm going in, like, mostly blind.
I was like, I don't want to see anything.
I kind of want to just...
I want to...
I want to just experience it.
No spoilers.
I'm excited.
I'm half blind.
But what we could do is play Snake versus Monkey in the...
meantime can I try it I still haven't played it you have an eye patch that's 50% blind I'm 50% blind go for it let's go for it this is snake I've made it to the sneaking point you're right on time snake yeah for being dragged out of the sack at 2 in the morning I did my best rise and shine don't you love mornings Love warnings.
Nobody loves being dragged away from their vacation.
I'm sorry, but we needed you.
Something big is going down.
Very big.
That's why.
Oh.
So what is this important mission?
Look at him, Roy Campbell.
Voice Paul Heiding!
Oh my gosh!
That's so cute!
Any mental gears.
Don't worry.
He's six foot five, five, eighth inches.
If it's like a hot damsel in distress, I'll think about it hot damsel not quite a hot damsel in distress princess at the top of the tower is a rescue mission rescuing who apes apes but not just any monkeys what you said monkeys just listen minkees is to infiltrate the jungle and capture all of the monkeys again you said monkeys yes monkeys this isn't really my thing if you want your monkeys you better have spike or Jimmy unfortunately they weren't available how about me I was on vacation ah we need you if you don't do this who will so true it's not like someone else couldn't handle a stealth mission Jimmy don't say that who's spike or Jimmy we turned over every leaf end why don't you make Sam or Gabe do Sam?
Isn't this just some splinter cell?
Snake?
I'm asking you.
It's a request from the professor himself.
The professor?
Natalie's grandfather?
Yep, escape emcees.
That's the one.
The one who came up with the monkey helmet?
Well, that was the professor's classmate.
His classmate?
From high school.
Gave his siphon filter.
Gave dark protocol.
Wait.
He's Otakon's friend too.
Oh, Otakon!
It's because of the professor that Otakon has been able to come up with.
with some of his inventions all right what are the details so you'll do it great I'm not against some monkey catching monkey catching rather be collecting pants what the monkeys have fled into the jungle when you what does he mean by that what does he mean but I'm not going to be able to grab them when they're jumping all around the place right right when you've grabbed all the monkeys Your mission is complete.
Huh?
Commencing Operation Ape Snake.
Ape Snake.
When you capture a monkey, yell out the password.
With the password, a warp device will activate.
Pants.
Good.
I'm counting on you, Snake.
Yes, Colonel.
Ape fear.
Wait one second.
Unfortunately, I got a high fever today, so I can't play Fox on online.
launch.
No, JK, I don't feel better.
I heard it could be a new app.
Oh, we'll see, I guess, in 47 minutes.
We'll see.
Whoa, whoa.
Music.
Whoa.
Gone with the apes.
I wanted to say awesome job in Koa's chaos requiem for it yesterday.
Your singing was absolutely beautiful.
It was super nice.
You didn't make time for it.
What a pleasure to hear you sing.
Thank you.
Yeah, I was in Koa's concert.
She invited me.
And we got to sing Wake Up Girls Together, which is one of my favorite series ever.
Return of the Living Apes.
The Apes of Wrath.
Let's do it.
Let's do Escape from the Jungle.
Snake dashingly rescuing someone, wearing a curious George costume, and blushing Sen Super Chat.
Why the Curious George costume?
Why?
For anybody who doesn't know, there was one time when I was like, we-whisp, I had a friend whose mom worked at a college as a professor.
And she was like, hey, I need a kid to...
to dress up as a monkey and cause mischief.
And I know the perfect kid for that.
And it was me.
And so my friend, he dressed up as the man, the yellow hat, and I was Curious George because I think it was like a, I think it was like a, how do you say, like a anniversary or something for Curious George.
And so I got to run around into classrooms and I got to jump on tables, and I got to, I was mostly in the library, and I was like jumping around as Curious George, and I was just causing a ruckus.
I got to skip school, and then I got to brag to everybody that I dressed up as a monkey and didn't have to go to class.
But the reason I remember it so vividly, well, part of the reason, besides it being so awesome was I there was one point where I was like I'm gonna jump up on this table and I go to jump up on the table and I hit my knees so bad like you know how it's like there's a part in your knee that's almost like a funny bone I hit that part and I like literally my vision went black I saw stars I fell to the ground and I was like And they were like,
curious, George, stop.
Stop.
Get off the floor, George.
You're such a...
You're making so much noise in the library.
I was not...
Oh, I remember that.
It was so bad.
I was just like...
I was like, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Oh,
it hurt so bad.
Have you ever seen the episode where George had to manage all of the trains?
I don't think I've ever seen an episode of Curious George.
I don't think I've ever seen an episode.
I think I just winged it.
I'm a method actress.
Such a minky.
That's like how it was made for me, maybe.
And after that, George was never curious ever again.
We gotta get 10 monkeys!
How do I catch them?
Come here, monkey.
Oh my god, they're so cute.
Come here!
Oh my god, he's beating me up!
Wait, oh my god, he's beating me up all the time!
Wait, what did the instruction say?
I couldn't...
Let me run after him.
Come here.
How do I grab him?
Oh!
Gotcha!
I think I was about to run out of time even.
Shoot.
No, bro!
Okay.
Come here!
Gotcha!
It's so quiet now.
Wait.
Oh.
Come here, monkey.
Oh!
Oh, whoop.
Sorry.
Oh, oh.
Gotcha.
Oh, wait.
My time isn't going down.
It's going up.
I'm silly.
Oh, my Oh, I just had!
Special!
It was Astro Bot!
Oh my god!
It wasn't even an actual bug, it was Astro Bot!
You're mine!
Wait, how do I...
How do I get him, though?
Go up?
Wait, go up?
Oh, climb, sorry.
How do I get this guy?
Oh.
Oh, where'd he go?
Ah?
Ah!
Oh!
Where are you going?
Oh, okay.
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, dang, that was close.
Oh, that was close.
That was...
Where are you going?
Hold on!
Hold on, my key!
There's a path up there.
Well, I never knew.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Is this the last monkey?
No, we have many more.
Oh wait, there's one right there!
Don't say minky, eh?
I'm using tilt controls.
Okay.
Bam, snake.
Well, wait, where's the pathway then?
Oh, over here.
There must be more.
Oh!
Ah!
Holy cow.
Scared me.
I'm using tilt controls.
Gotcha.
I never knew this was up here.
Wait, I can't go this way.
There's still two more.
Little monkey.
Little monkey, where are you?
Nice gifts.
Oh my gosh.
Say elf.
Thank you so much for that gift.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, I really appreciate it.
Aha!
Look at him crawling.
Gotcha!
One more monkey for my collection!
Where could you be?
Where are you at?
Little monkey.
Come home with me!
Whisp chasing after Minky the Ghost who's causing mischief.
Yeah.
Well, if you have fun tonight, unfortunately, Foxhunt launches way past my old man time on work nights.
I know, it's so late, right?
Whatever, consider original ape escape.
Yeah, I would like to play them.
Guys, we have one monkey lost.
Where could he be?
This is the first level.
level in the trees maybe he's hanging over the ledge no bottom right
where could it be i
heard him i thought i did i heard him
speed running time It's already fultoned out of here.
No!
Hold on.
I'm gonna look around.
Why is this guy eluding me so much?
I don't remember where he is.
He's really hidden for me.
Hiding in the garage.
But I would see his hat.
No?
What is this mode?
Why have I forgotten how to...
Okay, here we go.
I was like, I've forgotten how to...
Okay, we only have scope.
I've forgotten how to use the controls in this game.
Let's try the mic.
Are those monkey noises?
Oh my god!
What's wrong with him?
Why is he screeching?
Oh.
Talented.
No wonder I couldn't find him.
Oh.
Are you okay?
I didn't get a good score.
That's okay, though.
Drag net of the apes yeah poor guy hit every branch on the way down oh my god whoa wait there's 17 i like how they put their hands on their on their booties it's fun see how many i can take out just like do they wake up their friends you know look at them go oh oh oh Oh.
What?
Do you get out of time for...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, what the hell?
Hello?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Let me shoot you.
There we go.
He blocked the shot!
Astrobot!
Oh my
god!
I swear.
Save him!
Wait, do I shoot?
Astrobot?
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
They wake up really fast, actually.
Okay, hold on.
Ow!
Gotcha!
Guys, I think this is like, this mode specifically feels made for me.
I'm obsessed.
The pose is too good.
You're mine.
And so are you.
Oh, I winked, but you couldn't tell.
It's my birthday tonight!
Wait, what did he say?
What is he doing?
Why is he freaking out like that?
Go on to the Metal Gear Solid series because of you.
Oh my goodness, that guy was aggressive.
Boy, I didn't get to see the rest of your message.
Camouflage.
Wait, who saw me?
Oh.
He's dodging?
Why does he do that?
Wait, oh my gosh, if I aim, there we go.
Oh, just kidding.
I don't want to shoot this guy.
He's going through it.
Oh, he looks like me these past couple of days.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
We just box him up.
Oh.
I feel like we're getting the really obvious ones.
Whoop!
I'm bullying.
Should miss my super.
What?
I'm playing a timed mode.
I'm sorry.
I'll go back and rid once I'm done.
Well, I guess it doesn't really...
It looks so...
It's just...
It looks so like...
Wait.
Bonk, bonk, bonk.
Lion King.
You had me dying near the end of Harvester when you said, Mommy, you're so good.
You're so good.
Mommy, you're so good.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Wait.
Let's see.
Secret of Minky Island.
I hear...
Oh!
I see him.
I see that guy too!
You're sleepy.
Oh!
That was it!
Yippee!
Oh!
yes feels so good oh my gosh only 30 minutes left
oh the stun grenades yeah i like shooting them though 25 maybe we'll have to use the stun grenades though here my goodness
i love this place because it's the first time we ever meet him.
What?
Whoa, there's a huge party!
Minky!
That's me.
Don't wear it out.
What are they crawling around there for?
I can't line it up at all.
Oh, bad shot.
They're crawling.
This guy is just, like, walking normal.
Okay.
100% summon the crawl space.
Oh yeah, I was thinking that too.
That was 100% thinking that too.
The embrace.
He doesn't even notice his friend isn't talking to him anymore.
Oh.
The music is killing me.
Run,
run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
Maybe not his friend.
He's like, yeah, I'm glad that guy's out.
Glad that guy's out of the picture.
Okay, we'll definitely...
We'll stun grenade these friends.
Oh.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't have been looking at it.
You have a revolver.
Yeah.
Wombo-combo!
Holy moly.
Oh, this guy here too.
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
He woke up.
Hey!
Wait, I think he was...
Wait, I want to see what he was doing.
Oops.
Hey, don't be...
Don't be...
Oops.
Whoop!
Who saw me?
Oops.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so stupid.
Oh my god.
I can't shoot.
Guys.
Ow!
Dang it!
Yeah, Astrobot's a little guy in this game too.
It's so fun.
So happy he's around.
Like, what are the odds that I love Astrobot so much?
And... Ah!
Ay!
You!
Stankin' monkeys!
This is how everybody in the college felt.
Astrobot, don't worry, I'm not gonna shoot you yet.
No!
Oh my gosh.
Here, mine!
Wait, give me up there.
Give me up there.
Oh gosh, my controller.
Give me.
Woo!
Um, where did the out of strobot go?
Where'd the music...
Oh, there it's coming from here!
That's so cute.
Oh, this guy's just drinking a cup of...
Grab him!
I think I'm...
That's my favorite one.
Ah!
Oh.
Did he just throw...
He's throwing rocks at me!
Oh my gosh.
Hey.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
There we go.
I interrupted his cuppa.
I sure did.
Yeah, I saw what you were doing on the bed.
One little monkey jumping on the bed.
What's he doing there?
Yeah.
I definitely...
Oh.
She scared me.
Got you.
You're mine.
Any monkeys underneath?
I hear one.
Any monkeys in here?
How are you supposed to do these missions in a minute?
How?
There's no monkey in the crawl space?
I feel like I got...
Oh, I haven't tried the roof, you're right.
But I still feel a little cheated.
You probably have to memorize all the monkey locations, yeah.
Oops, whoa, sorry.
I was... I accidentally hit the trigger.
Wherever you are!
Oh, nope!
I clicked retry on action and sorry.
Three, two, I won't.
There we go.
I don't want to do...
retries just because we have...
What's the word?
Limited time.
Speed run!
I know the victory pose is too good.
21 ape fear.
Whoa.
If anybody can read Russian, what does that say?
Mesogear?
What did...
Oh.
Oh, that was close.
This is running.
running around.
I can also get you.
Got you.
They wake up so quickly.
Oh my gosh.
Take them down.
Even still, I feel like I'm so slow to be able to get all these guys and an amp in a, you know, decent amount of time.
Minky gear.
Wow, look at him up there!
Oh my gosh!
Too cute.
This mode is the best.
What are they doing in there?
Oh.
Some new sort of waza.
Oh!
Somebody saw me.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, sorry, I was looking at it again.
My bad.
How did you?
Wait, why aren't you asleep?
I only got one guy.
Ah!
Me,
so gear!
Oh, where'd they go?
Oh.
I love the proud...
Proud father is so good.
We're looking away?
Gotcha!
It's Astroba!
You're mine!
I wonder if the guy is like up...
I guess they would just jump back if I didn't get...
Get them in time.
Who's...
Who spotted me?
Oh, whoops.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
It's so sensual.
Are they inside here, too?
Oh, no.
Oh.
Ah!
It's a good thing I looked, though.
That guy was tricky.
It's a good thing.
It's a monkey.
Don't run from me.
You're pretty good.
Thanks.
Wait, do you think there's one inside?
Nope.
Okay, I don't think we can go inside any of the buildings.
I hear you.
I don't...
Oh my gosh.
Don't die.
Dive.
Don't die either.
Oh my gosh.
Stop teasing me.
I am.
I'm doko.
I'm using tilt controls.
Please excuse.
Please excuse my dear Aunt Sally.
Okay.
one guy is up here.
But I want to get him last.
I hear one.
Maybe up on the roof?
I want to get that guy last.
Maybe on the rooftop.
My dear Aunt Sally is excused.
Thank you.
Oh!
Wait, what are you doing?
Is that a ration?
That's not for monkeys.
disgusting wait why are we inside all of a sudden from here on out you're a big boy cemento sick flip oh dang
all done we shall never excuse her dear i was only a minute ish less than the minute behind third place okay 17 minutes left gone with the apes why is snake doing that why is snake doing that i love i love this mode i want to try the bomber man mode too but i actually think i prefer this because it's like a scavenger hunt kind of deal it's so fun No reading on the job!
Job!
Oh, oh.
Oh!
How did I...
Oh, cool.
Nice, I got them both at the same time.
Who's in here?
Oh, gosh, it scared me.
Lazy bones over there.
Ah, don't hit me.
Oh.
Let's go run and grab...
Ah!
Oh!
Get him!
There's a Bomberman mode?
Yeah, but it's only for...
Oh, it's so...
It's so sensual.
It's only for Xbox.
Stop!
Stop it!
Where'd he go?
That other guy.
Oh!
Where?
Oh, hey!
Come back here!
Ah!
Oh, dang, he dodged.
Stop resisting.
Alright.
So far.
Not bad.
Oh, timing.
Oh, that could have been better.
Oh, my gosh.
Don't do that.
I did save Astrobot, but did he want to be saved?
Oh.
You're mine!
This guy looks traumatized.
I like how we suddenly...
Oh.
What the hell was he about to do?
He was staring at the grab-your-model!
Naughty monkey.
Naughty naughty.
Oh, oops, my bad.
Ow!
That's fine, I got him.
Wait, who else is out here?
Who else is out here?
on me.
So far, we're making great time, though.
Wait, come on, come on, come on.
Oh, over there, over there.
No!
Bad time!
No, no!
Don't leave!
Oh my gosh, please.
Ah!
Okay, okay, I got him.
Happy year to have, Vicky!
Thank you, souls!
Thank you!
Okay.
Just saw Kana Udo's new mint video.
Wait, what?
What did that guy do?
I don't even know what you're talking about.
Huh?
What did that guy do?
Oh.
I hear monkey.
Gamers don't look up.
Monkey not up.
Monkey.
Monkey missing.
Missy monkey?
Okay.
I don't think we're making time.
Gotcha.
Uh.
Oh.
Maybe I can get him in time.
Oh my gosh.
I did.
but I don't know if I can grab these guys and him at the same time!
Wait, there's one more?
No?
Ah, I don't think I'm
getting...
Good time, good time.
Okay?
Go, go, go.
Go, go, go!
Suddenly we're outside.
Um... Oh!
Oh!
Dang it.
Wait, where do you go?
Suddenly we're outside again.
Oh no, I don't think that it's going to make it.
Maybe it will.
Yes!
What the hell do I get to the guy over on the other side?
There was a guy over here, right?
Oh, sheesh.
Wait, drop.
Drop.
Snake.
Or don't.
Don't break your ankles today, fine.
Two more!
Oh gosh.
Drop.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to...
I didn't press let go.
Let go.
This way?
We need to find that other guy.
What can I do?
What does that guy do?
You guys are scaring me.
No.
Oh.
Eh?
Monkey.
Oh, uh-uh.
Look in my suit.
It's full of bananas.
It looks really delicious to you, but...
How do I get to the outside?
What?
What is this?
Oh, climb.
Is there a monkey up?
Monkey down?
Monkey all around?
Maybe I shoot him?
and then it falls.
I doubt it, but I could try.
I was right.
My gamer instincts.
Gotcha.
You're mine.
Okay, I think we do have to use the microphone for this last guy, though.
Oh.
Upstairs, maybe?
My gamer instinct.
Last monkey.
We had such a good time at first.
Is it down there?
It's so quiet now.
Maybe he is downstairs.
Hold on.
I don't want to go downstairs just yet.
Maybe he was in the bathroom.
Oh,
thank you for the pre-thumbrax!
Welcome everybody!
I love this game.
Way too much.
We have less than 10 minutes until...
Until, until...
Oh, I guess we could do...
Which one should we do?
The one with missile gear or should we do the one in the...
This one seems to be quite short because it doesn't have a lot of time or...
Probably less monkeys.
Thank you guys for the...
gifted!
I guess you have two Murphy!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you guys!
Try and do both?
Okay, we can do both!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Well, this one's 16.
Oh wait, I did it out!
Wait, I did it out of order!
My bad.
WMJ, thank you!
Oh my gosh, the Kappa.
Three, two, one, start!
Oh!
Oh, he's right in front of me.
I can't see the...
If I...
Oh my gosh, wait, oh my gosh, oh no!
One of them didn't go to sleep.
Startle!
Happy birthday!
It kind of feels kind of messed up being in here, I feel.
Wait, oh my gosh.
What?
Wait, did I not get him?
Oh, I know.
There's just gonna be monkeys everywhere running around!
Sorry I didn't get to actually read your super chat, but I can see everybody.
Oh.
I got... I couldn't see the crosshair.
Oh, maybe how does she...
Maybe.
Oh my gosh, I still can't see the crosshair sometimes.
Sometimes it's so tricky.
With my eyes.
Fun!
So lame!
Is it because they had glasses?
Oh.
Oh, geez.
I know I'm just gonna...
Oh, that was Astrobot.
Oh my gosh, there's a guy here!
Wait, move, move, move!
Wait, move!
I suck at this!
My Virgo, happy birthday!
Sorry, I'm missing all of these.
It's because I'm trying to capture- Ow!
He's throwing rocks at me!
Oh, the petals turned red.
That's kind of messed up.
Oh my gosh, I can't see my crosshair.
Where's my crosshair?
Oh, there it is.
And I can't hit him.
That's Astrobot!
Get up, Snake.
Astrobot.
He is astrobot.
Not a monkey.
This guy's throwing the rocks.
I'm really...
Really stinking rude of you.
Get ready.
rocked he's rocking my world you know what i mean
you think i get no i'm just gonna take them down with my hands take them down with my hands
oh oh i couldn't see my crosshair sorry Why is it so hard for me today?
It's because I'm half blind.
Wait, wait, there's one more.
He's not on top of the...
Oh, there he is.
He's just been chilling this whole time.
I've been fighting for my afterlife.
I had a nickel for every MGS obsessed Oshi I'd have.
Okay, I'd have a nickel.
Here's a few nickels.
What is this pose?
Spank, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
We have five minutes.
I think I can do this one and...
It might be a little longer than five minutes, but...
But...
That will give time for maybe if it needs like a minute.
YouTube recommended your cover of Snake Eater to me.
Almost made me cry!
Did you have training and singing?
A little.
Um, just only as a kid, though.
Three, two, one.
Bing!
Bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong!
I was gonna say there's gotta be a guy up here.
All those monkeys are on top of missile gear!
This is no place to be monkeying around!
Gotcha!
Can I drop?
Whew!
You okay, Snake?
Sorry.
Maybe I can get all of them.
Oh, that was pretty good!
Wait, that was... that was clean!
That was so clean!
Ape Eater!
Bombo combo, baby!
Nice!
That was clean!
That was the cleanest I'll ever have ever!
Da-da-da-da!
Is there anybody over here?
Okay.
Wait, I see somebody up there though.
We can go this way.
Bum-bum.
Okay.
You never know.
Wait, they're gonna see me for real.
Bum-bum.
Maybe not.
The guy chungling.
Oh wait, I'm sorry.
I didn't look.
I didn't look away.
I forgot.
Such is the case with me.
Since I first played NGS3 on the first raid on PS2, I missed out on this game mode.
I can do this.
Wait.
What?
Okay.
I think the game bugged for me as far as I can.
Why does he do that?
Proud father.
Bear hug.
Big, big hug.
We still have 10 monkeys.
I mean...
Oh, shoot.
I think he loves the monkeys.
But not in love with the monkeys.
I hear them screaming above me.
You think there's going to be any guys in here?
Oh, maybe not.
Maybe down over here.
Wait, I think I hear one.
I don't think I hear one.
Oh.
No one.
Oh, wait.
No one hiding?
For real?
One minute left!
I'm so excited!
So I mentioned the pinpost, but I will be playing...
I'm on PC, obviously.
So I don't think there's a cross.
Uh oh, wait, I gotta be fast.
I gotta be real fast.
Gotcha.
Wait, I gotta be super fast.
So, um, wait, how do I get up there over here?
Do do do do do.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, did they all leave?
They did!
They're all freaked out!
Uh oh, wait, uh, I...
I was holding down my D-pad and it for some reason wasn't switching.
And then I forgot to look away.
I did get that guy.
No!
I got your booty!
Draw!
That was a good pose too.
Why would you look so sad?
Why would you look so sad being held by a snake like that?
Couldn't be.
Wait, hold on.
I'll never let go.
I'll never let...
Oh, dang it.
Oh, I need to get up there.
Ah, okay.
I'll never let go, John.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, you...
Actual bastard.
Ah!
Where'd he go?
Throwing rocks at me!
He heard that.
Yeah, he did.
Um...
Where else?
We have one more!
Where could he be?
I guess let's just check the other side.
I haven't gone over there.
Draw!
Oh, that's why you guys are saying that.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the film to be gifted.
Thank you.
Okay, I lost him.
Maybe he's right here.
No?
I hear him?
Oh, my gosh.
Please, please, snake.
Snake, snake, snake, stop.
Snake, get up.
What's he doing?
He's like jumping all around.
Maybe.
I don't think so.
I don't think under.
Is he up top?
Oh yeah, he's definitely up there.
Oh yeah.
I have to go all the way around again.
Well, while I'm getting this last guy.
You all.
Wait, I think he's going to jump down, though, as soon as I...
like walk past missile gear.
It's 25 gigs!
Holy cow!
It's an update.
Okay, okay, thank you.
There he is!
He won't let me hang.
Hang!
No, please!
Snake, please!
Snake, stop!
Oh my gosh.
sake got him we made it somehow all
right now i close my game banana cap this item will be added to all save data as an item in your inventory what does it do banana cap gold
woohoo super chat you didn't catch earlier was to ask for your blessing to cosplay you as a guy oh Oh, thank you.
Of course.
Please.
Cosplay me.
However.
Thank you.
Even if you're like one of those guys that cosplays.
But like.
Where's the dress and has like a crazy beard.
That's okay too.
Wait, how do I update my game?
Hmm?
The Toho cosplayers I need to close and restart Steam Let's try Goodbye Wait No I don't want to exit Steam Because it might close out of everything Stim
Let me Gold Metal Gear Oh Metal Gear is on sale right now everybody pst metal gear is on sale right now it's in my library okay if I disappear I'm so sorry if I disappear don't forget about me
if I disappear remember me
oh do you snake versus monkey gave an ape escape mask as a reward but delta gives banana cap since they didn't want ape escape mascot with gun that's so cute actually i'll come back i'll come i'll be back i'll be back 25 gigs let's see how fast it will if it will download for me oh update update update yeah i'm so excited
And I'm also back.
Monkey with gun.
It's downloading 2%.
3%.
4%.
Mint, quit fooling around.
Mint?
Mint!
What kind of tricks should I do while we wait?
hold on let me do this too well no no no that's what we do let's begin a flip i'm gonna show you the most impressive thing you've ever seen in your life
smooth My head was like the focus point there.
So smooth.
What else?
What else can I do for you?
What can I do for you?
Let's do that.
Hold on.
Let me write a note in case anybody comes in and they're just like, what the hell is she doing?
That changed my life?
It's National Cat Day, apparently.
It is!
Should I be minki?
Can you take me out to dinner?
Take a girl out to dinner first.
Everyone stop chatting.
Downloading all of our comments.
It's taking up minki's bandwidth.
It's at 16%.
I know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to sing a song about what can I do for you?
Hmm?
What's that song called?
song called wait
oh yeah yeah yeah okay
let's see if this works no not that one this one okay does this work okay yeah stand on your hands or head please oh my arms are down here My eyes are up here!
I'm singing.
In the void.
Is it gonna load?
Hello?
What can I do for you?
I
fly beyond the hazy borders of my heart I can see a place, it's something like this Every now and then I don't know what to do Still I know that I can never go back All the things I've seen in those hazy dreams Can't compare to what I see tonight Everything's so different That it brings me to my knees And oh,
I know surrounded me I won't give into it now I know that world is is the only way my heart can go I hear your voice calling out to me you'll never be alone what can I do for you what can I do for you 50% what can I do for you what can I do for you I don't plan on looking back on my own life I don't ever plan to feel I own you Even by chance everything should go wrong You come in one day and try to save me If from time to time it's an upward climb All I know is that I must believe Cause the truth I'm seeking always was inside of me And the real emotion has surrounded me The many things that you taught me then Will always be enough to get me through the pain Because of you I am strong enough To know I'm not alone 75,
76, 77% Oh my gosh, 78!
Wait, the song might be over by the time it's done!
What can I do for you?
I can hear you And if I find the real without the motion Has surrounded me And I can't go on And you are there The moment that I close my eyes You comfort me We are connected for all of time I'll never be alone I know the world of real emotion Has surrounded me Don't give in to it now I know that forward is the only way my heart can go I hear your voice calling out to me It's time to play Fox Hunt What can I do for you?
I can hear you What can I do for you?
What can I do for you?
I can hear you I can hear you.
Yeah!
Perfect timing!
That was incredible!
Alrighty.
All it took was one song.
God, this...
this title screen just makes me...
Oh yeah.
Foxhunt!
So you went to exit Metal Gear Solid Delta Snake and open Foxhine, yeah.
It is a separate win-
Back to Apescape.
One second.
Oh, gosh, everything is...
Everything is different?
Everything is new?
And scary, and I probably need to fix my...
Yeah, I'm lagging.
Oh, game lag.
Oh, game really lag.
Oh, I'm from the United States of America.
Ah!
You want me to pick a place?
New York!
Agree.
I have to.
Pick Alaska.
Oh, I shouldn't pick Alaska.
I pick New York as MGS2.
Fox unit cadets.
Wait, but I want to fix my window, please.
The purpose of Fox unit members is to improve the abilities required of Fox unit members and to determine which of you operatives are best suited to serve in the unit.
Snake Stoke blob.
We ask that you use Fox Hunt to hone your skills and prove that you have what it takes to serve in this unit.
Well, I'm still East Coast.
We have prepared a slideshow for you to watch.
All Fox Hunt missions are based on actual battle scenarios.
scenarios faced by Fox Unit out in the field.
Therefore, your gear is limited to just your survival knife and AT camera.
Oh.
Everything else will need to be procured on site.
Ah, I'm used to that.
The on-site procurement of weapons and equipment needed to complete a mission will be simulated here through the use of supply boxes.
Additionally, in order to maximize your training efficiency, we will be evaluating you across a series of mission phases.
At the end of each phase, those that fail to advance will be battle royale.
What?
This is your all-terrain camouflage suit, otherwise known as AT Camo.
AT Camo.
Pulling a rip cord attached to your bag activates a gas canister that automatically deploys and equips your suit.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Including stored gilly parts as well.
If you deploy gilly parts that match your surroundings, it'll make your camo even more effective.
looks like chocolate you've mastered it as part of your training but i'd like to go over the topic of naked sense once more naked sense is a special new technique that sharpens your five senses in order to help you search your surroundings it enables you to detect threats and supplies in your vicinity okay naked sense next i'd like to go over the rules for each mission type mission survival The mission type is designed to mimic infiltration missions to focus on retrieving top secret materials or rescuing important individuals.
It's a escort mission.
You need to track the asset and secure it before the completion of each phase, or you will be removed from the mission.
No!
Mission, survival, intrusion.
Can you guys carry me?
This mission type is designed to mimic infiltration missions focused on retrieving an asset and securing a landing zone until an allied helicopter arrives.
In a designated zone at the end of each phase Or you will be removed from the mission That concludes the briefing It is like a battle royale There is no time to waste So please start making your preparations for the mission I wish you luck That's me Baby
Mission basics Fox hunt consists of various missions designed to improve The abilities required of Fox unit members And to see which operatives Are the best of the best Missions consist of two players per team and can feature up to a total of 12 players.
As phases progress, any players who do not meet the requirements will be removed from the mission and the last surviving team will successfully complete the mission.
The requirements for completing a phase differ according to the mission type.
In order to accomplish your mission, it is important to not just eliminate your enemies, but to know when to stay hidden and avoid detection as well.
Oh, starting a mission while on base camp.
Then he can create the room!
Wait!
This is fine.
You can also move to survival room from here.
Please make your preparations for the upcoming mission.
That's a me!
Wait!
Wait, hold on real quick.
Oh, mission types.
The survival capture and survival intrusion.
You will not know which type of mission you will be facing until the mission starts.
Oh, okay, so you don't get to...
I'll give you a brief overview of the survival capture mission type.
I just want to fix my...
Please, my window is all messed up.
I just want to fix it.
Survival capture is a mission type where you must work to secure assets and survive until the mission is over.
At the start of each phase, special Kedotan target items will appear throughout the phase.
Press X to retrieve a...
Wait.
Oh, okay.
I was like, wait, my controller doesn't have X.
I'm stupid.
It's...
It dies.
X to retrieve a Kedotan.
you come across once each phase has ended.
Any players holding a Keto town will complete the phase.
Oh.
Now to explain about the survival intrusion mission type.
I'm dumb.
I didn't read the last one.
Survival intrusion is a mission where you must stay within the area known as zones and survive until...
Because they're just a battle royale.
I'm playing Metal Gear Fortnite right now.
Start of each phase.
Special targets known as Gakko appear.
throughout the field that can be used to activate zones by attacking the gako once each phase has ended any players that have stood inside his own for the required amount of time will complete the phase you can activate naked sense to pinpoint the gako's i think i'm gonna be really bad at this but that's okay wait is there not a way for me to like oh here we go here we go oh my goodness oh oh yeah okay one second guys
Like the window is so big for me?
I can't change it?
Oh.
Okay.
Well?
It doesn't seem to be lagging anymore.
Maybe it's okay.
Maybe.
it's fine.
Oh.
Maybe it's fine.
I think this is all that I...
I think this is all the same that I had for the other game.
Like, like actual snake eater.
So I think... We'll just...
We'll just see.
How's the new game mode?
We just started.
Like, literally.
What is this?
This is your all-terrain camouflage suit.
Ah!
Otherwise known as AT Camo.
Okay.
LB.
to open the window and oh my gosh select a pattern wait what?
LB and then select the pattern and release and it'll deploy it you can also press Lee quickly press Lee quickly press LB Metal Gear Fortnite Delta hold on I need to I'm a visual learner there's so much text
wait there's not like ah okay no it's not picking up my mic or anything that would be so horrible oh like this wow
i become a rock it looks really obvious i'm not blending in at all oh my tree i'm a tree damn that booty though Holy tree bark.
Octo Camo.
Kind of, yeah.
Your motion indicator is a device that indicates how easy it is to detect you.
In other words, it provides a visual representation of just how much you stand out.
Oh, okay.
Oh, okay, interesting.
Okay, so that's not...
I thought it was my mic, but it's a motion indicator.
Okay.
Please prepare for battle.
Hold on, hold on.
Oh, oh, and so this is how poison
Poison Poison gears Wait, did I just throw it on the ground?
Did I throw something on the ground?
I'm sure you've mastered it as part of your training Or B I'd like to go over the topic of naked sense Once more Okay Yeah
I said that
Wait, do I have a gun?
Oh
What is this?
Camel decoy.
Piece of shit marker.
Wait, he's in there.
I know it.
I can't...
I felt him in there.
Wait, is he gonna see me?
And shoot me?
Oh!
Oh.
I'm out of ammo.
Do I not know CQC or?
Oh, I do.
Okay.
Oh, yeah!
Took his butt down.
Oh, just kidding.
He's stronger.
He's tougher than it looks.
Wait, what's this one?
Backpack.
Item's ammo and other gear you acquire are stored in your backpack.
I have a backpack?
Oh my god, there's inventory back.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Going to school.
Drop shot.
The drop shot is a technique that can be used to get enemies to drop items when you catch them off guard.
No way I can get people to shake down somehow.
Oh no I'm just so... Oh my gosh.
That's evil.
Wait.
I think I hate this.
I think I'm...
Wait, get me out of this.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, it's X.
My bad.
Um...
Funny and evil.
I think...
What is... No, this is...
This one.
I'm grass.
That's... I said that.
Okay, sorry.
I'm just getting a sense of...
for everything before we...
Go in, you know?
What are these?
Oh, open.
Open?
Oh, I have to hold it.
Oh, okay, and it takes like a second to do it.
Oh, okay.
Interesting, okay.
Supply boxes contain random supplies such as weapons, ammo, and food.
Hold X, okay.
Okay.
How do I get inside?
Oh, here?
Just kidding.
Oh, okay.
I want to see them.
Oh, here's the Gakul.
What?
So then what do I do with the Gakul?
Do I shoot them?
No.
Fortnite has...
Fortnite.
has changed.
Me using like this big old gun little gawko right in front of me.
Okay.
I'm scared.
I'm scared, but I guess I'll try.
Look at me.
I'm just a little ducky.
Wait, so if I start mission, do I create a room or do I start the mission?
Loud-ass sniper.
I'm No.
This is so not my type of game.
But, well, we will be fine maybe.
Create room is probably for parties.
I want to create a room then maybe so that we can all...
So you guys can get in instead, you know?
So, could I have fun?
Yeah, we're just here to have fun, so whatever.
I'll create a room.
See what happens.
mission after forming a team with another member take on the mission with pre-selected members so i guess this is friends like it's
a lot more than i thought it was gonna be i know
hello what's the black box it's different they did say it's something about
oh whoa this one's good
oh that's a lot of I thought somebody joined.
Is there a room ID?
Oh!
I think I have to...
Wait.
But is it just gonna be...
I thought we were playing with a bunch of people.
I'm so confused.
Should I show the room ID then or...
Do custom.
You chose duo.
Okay, okay.
So we'll...
Well, that's why I thought custom was friends only.
Obviously that's not... that wouldn't be good for you.
So create room, custom.
Let's see.
Oh!
Ow!
Okay.
Okie dokie.
Are you guys ready?
There we go.
Okie dokie.
Ready?
Alright, well obviously...
What we'll do is, I'm not sure how many games we'll be able to get through today.
I do have a meeting at 11.
I do have a meeting at 11, so if you play a game, please only join once, unless we're struggling to find people.
But yeah, just join only once, please.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Three, a two, a one, and show.
Oh wow, it's so short.
We expected a really long code or something.
839471.
One of your fellow members has joined the...
One of your fellow members has joined...
Oh!
Wait, I think we need one more?
One of your fellow...
Oh, there it is!
Yay!
Oh my god!
Cure?
Who's hurting?
Oh my god!
Hey!
I mean, this is so stupid.
I'm out.
Hey!
Go to the mold!
Hold on, I'm gonna scoot over just a tad.
There you guys go.
Okay.
I just hear grunting men.
Let me get up!
Oh my gosh!
Ugh!
They're throwing grenades and everything!
Oh my gosh, it's a poison grenade.
Oh!
I'm gonna cure.
I'm treating my injury.
Stop!
I'm treating my injury!
What's going on?
Stop!
Let me treat my injury!
Oh my god!
Stop it!
Oh, wait, I'm lost.
How do I start the game?
game.
Oh, battle preparation is complete.
Everybody, ready up.
We can't start the game until you're ready up.
It's a literal war zone.
Ready up, everybody.
Ready up.
Get off of me.
Diamond Wisp training going well.
Nobody's respecting me and my authority.
Wait, is that rare?
It's so...
Wait, I want to see!
I want to see!
Stop, stop, stop!
Wow.
This is not Diamond Dog behavior.
Take that.
Wow.
Uh, one more person needs to ready up.
CC!
You need to ready up!
He's already up.
Oh I think I'm about dead.
Stop it!
I'm gonna turn in the bark.
Nobody will see me here.
Let's die!
Okay here we go.
So crazy.
I'm scared.
Whoa!
Is this the location?
Where are we?
We're not in the jungles?
Code mine!
All right.
Where are leaves?
Whoa!
It's Silent Hill!
Wait, what are we doing?
Wait, Code Man, I'm scared.
Oh, we gotta find some Gakos.
Oh, this is the one where we find the...
Oh, there's a Gakos right near us.
Oh.
I'm scared.
What's that mean?
It's...
It's actually a Silent Hill up in here.
Oh, what's this?
I'm gonna pick it up.
I got a gun, okay.
Oh, wait.
Does that mean somebody's in there?
There's no Gokko over...
Oh, there is a Gokko over here.
Okay.
There's the enemy around here?
Two minutes remaining.
What do we do?
I'm scared.
I guess we could go in here.
Where is Agako?
Oh, he's right here!
Oh, I'm silly.
Um, what do I do with him?
How do I switch back to my...
Wait.
How do I...
Oh, wait, uh, wait, wait.
I don't want to use my back.
How do I...
I don't want to shoot it.
It's right here.
How do I activate it?
Knife, doko?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
All
right.
We're good.
I've secured the zone Silent fortnight solid craziness I'm gonna lay here And become a rock One minute remaining Good work Thank you I see somebody I see somebody I'm scared
He kicked me Oh Shoot him in the crotch Oh.
Enemy eliminated.
30 seconds remaining.
How do I reload again?
Can I get some ammo?
Oh, uh, how do I...
How do I do that?
How do I reload?
I have to keep an eye on the remaining time.
Um...
Is it X?
It is X.
You're right.
Good work.
Three!
Two!
One!
Ah!
Phase complete.
Zone status confirmed.
Phase two.
Oh, there's one right here.
Easy.
But we gotta be careful.
We're in plain sight.
Code man, we're in plain sight!
Oh!
kill if I see anybody.
I'm ready to kill.
So are you, apparently.
You're ready to kill.
She's a killer.
I'm ready to kill.
Oh, wait.
There's one...
Wait, could we just go back to the one that we did before?
We're doing so well.
Let's go.
Go!
Get in his butt!
I get in his butt!
Oh gosh!
I'm scared!
I have to become tree black.
Where'd that guy come from?
Wait, I left my mark here.
It's kind of crazy.
Where'd
that gas come from?
Am I crazy?
I'm here.
We're confirming.
Yeah.
Just a tree bark on this rock.
Wait, what's happening?
Who shooting at you?
I'll kill them.
How could you kill them?
30 seconds remaining oh my god oh i can redeploy wait where did i die uh uh hey hey how do i wait the current phase is nearly complete you must quickly make your way to the zone where am i select the location how do i here oh oh i can see your profiles yellow markers only oh like here Oh!
Oh!
I'm watching you guys!
I watched you.
Oh!
Oh no!
I'm watching you.
Who all is left?
I'm sorry.
It's all my fault.
Wait, there's only a couple people left.
I guess that's how the game goes, huh?
Oh yeah.
You use your naked sense rat sign.
Yeah.
Oh, that's your friend.
Did you both eat at the same- Oh my god!
Oh my god!
This is insane!
Kill him, kill him!
I don't know what the exclamation point means.
Oh, good job.
Yeah, kick his butt!
Sick fight.
You, Brie, you're the one who killed me.
Why would you do that?
Why?
Why do...
Why would you do that?
Answer me right now.
Give me a sign, Brie.
Give me a sign.
Is that the sign?
Is this the...
Is that...
Doggiza.
Baby.
One minute remaining.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, Anec.
Oh my gosh.
What's going on here?
T-bag apologies.
Oh no, oh no!
Wait!
Oh, it's Zone of the Enders.
How do you get those?
I want one.
Oh my gosh, the music is so dramatic.
You better win because you killed me.
You better win because you killed me!
Phase complete.
Oh!
Um...
This is the final phase.
Is he okay?
Just the two of them.
Wait, he made it.
Nice, wow, that was fast.
Wait, this is the only one, isn't it?
Now it's just like a...
Wait, that's the Shagohad!
I just realized!
You could have...
Is it?
You could have naked fight on top of it.
On top of it.
Yeah, look at him.
He's so cute.
Wait, I love this like beat up Groznygrad map.
It's so...
Oh.
It's so cool.
Wait, I actually really love this.
You could just hide and be a little baby and like never show your face in here.
Two minutes remaining.
where you guys are searching for each other oh my gosh starcross lovers sorry we lost boss code man you were pretty good i was also confused no you did amazing how did you talk to me so much how were you like so vocal we're on top of the shagohan that's so
Hello?
You could?
Oh my gosh, you know what would be sick is if you hit up here the whole time and then CC and then you did a flip into the zone with one second to spare.
Ah!
How many of you eave out?
This is so good.
One minute remaining.
I've...
I've yet to play a Metal Gear game but this intrigues me.
Oh!
You can wear the box!
Wait, that's- oh my god.
Where does this-
Ehh, kawaii, kawaii-sugiru.
Wait, does he know?
Does he know?
I can't tell.
Oh.
Hi!
30 seconds remaining.
Oh my gosh, you guys just- Ah!
Ah!
This is so good!
Oh, it's so good!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe you guys just did that towards each other.
Oh my god, that was so beautiful.
Yeah!
Oh,
sorry.
Sorry, so you see.
Bright, you won!
You did it after you killed him.
It is time to announce the top performing team.
Oh, the music.
Oh, congratulate!
I congratulated!
It was an honor, boss!
It is time to start the mission debriefing.
We got fourth!
Wait, but we didn't get fifth.
Actually, fourth is a spooky number.
We did a good job, code man.
Good job.
You did fairly well.
Ah!
See?
Oh, sorry.
All of the things, I can't see them.
my screen is cut off at the bottom hold on how do I, wait, I have to look through OBS what I press oh no, it's, it's okay, hold on oh,
switch info oh, okay, okay and then select what do I do how do I get out of here
might be 0xp for custom oh, that's okay though
Snake in Ozadar costume?
Thank you guys, thank you!
CC as your fellow Foxhound, I'm so proud you made it further than me.
GG's everyone.
It was so much fun, CC!
That was so good, that was so good.
This is so fun.
How do I emote though?
I want to emote.
How do I...
Wait.
Oh!
I found it.
You trying to hold me up, Uru?
You want me to shake my hips?
Uru?
Oh, wait.
It's not Uru.
Sorry.
Wait.
It was a...
You want me to shake my...
Pick my hips?
Blah!
What's this?
Yeah, I'm the bird, I'm the bird.
Greetings.
What's, thumbs up.
They're so cute.
Wait, the seeds are so cute.
Lean right.
Ooh.
Wait, this is, wait, if you lean right and somebody leans left.
Kawaii!
Wait, it's actually called.
It's kawaii!
Oh, it's such a bright day today!
Oh my gosh, wait.
If I also get outfit...
Oh my gosh, this is so cute.
If I also get like Ocelot, and then I can make him do all of this?
It's called free fall, but he's just team posing.
Kabuki.
It's only missing an MP3 player, so true!
Oh my gosh, these are so good.
These are so good!
Okay guys, I'm gonna create the room.
Wait, but how do I unlock XP to get outfits?
I guess I would have to play normal, huh?
Oh my gosh.
Custom room!
It's okay though.
Play online, but I wanna play with you guys.
so but also I feel bad subjecting any poor sap to my plating you know it's okay though alright are you guys ready for the next room heard if you play the non-custom mode you can unlock outfits more emotes poor AT camo titles and other cool unlockables I want to oh it's so tempting member stream but wouldn't it still I guess it would be
wait so you're okay subjecting us I mean you're used to it you're used to it yes I am on PC I am on PC you can run duos with somebody that's true that's true alright I'm gonna display the room code in three a two oh wait hold on before I do I don't know remember if you joined before please do not join again thank you three a two a one and display five six nine three six seven wow oh my god what a horrible code welcome
Come here!
Oh my god!
Everybody bully him!
Can't even let the man emote.
Stop stabbing me.
Are we ready?
Oh, wait.
I forgot we have to ready up.
Everybody ready up.
Ready up.
What?
Wait.
It's even...
Josh Keaton?
Oh.
I know your eyes a lot.
Wow.
Maybe it's not.
I can't tell.
Look at the...
How do you display the things?
I want one so bad.
My head is like up in there.
Wow.
Look at that one!
You got so many.
Don't forget to ready up, you guys.
We...
Lambress!
Wow.
It's like hurting cats.
Oh my gosh, these maps are so cool.
Survival intrusion.
Everybody in an awesome line.
Ryan, let's go, baby.
Let's go.
How many maps are there?
I have no idea.
The mission is about to begin.
If you are not within the specified...
Oh, it says this one again.
If you leave the phase, you will be removed from the mission.
Phase one.
Wait, there's...
I didn't get a single Gaka.
Okay.
Wait, maybe?
The enemy's close.
They are?
Scary!
Wait, what is this?
Medkit.
Wait, I need a weapon now.
Where'd you go, my friend?
Oh, there you are.
Oh, there's a big gun, big gun.
Did you get your gun?
Did you get one already?
I'll take this one.
Pick up.
Oh, I can't pick it up.
Why can't I pick it up?
Why won't I let me?
I don't want to let me grab it.
Why not?
Why?
Why won't I let me grab it?
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Two minutes remaining.
Inventory.
I shouldn't... Unless this recover life took up my entire inventory, I don't think so.
I'll follow you.
I'm a rook.
I feel like the hiding mechanic is not really like... I guess if you were like running around and didn't notice...
Check my equipment.
See?
Look, my backpack is completely full.
Friend, don't go.
Oh, over here.
Look at me!
What's happening to you?
Who's shooting you?
No!
I don't have a weapon to help you out!
Oh my gosh, we're gonna get out.
All because of me.
We gotta secure this guy.
He got me good.
Maybe I could get this one.
Wait, I see...
Is that a person right there?
Oh.
No, it's a rock.
They're firing on me too!
Wee!
Ah, that's a lot!
Hello!
Hi!
Wee, wee.
The current phase is nearly complete.
Oh!
Wait, what's happening?
Uh, game is glitching a little?
How do I do...
Oh no!
Um...
I gotta do this, or else we're done so.
Oh gosh!
Oh!
Ouch!
Um, yeah, they fired on You could do this...
I don't have... I didn't have a gun!
Better let me pick it up for some reason.
Take my... Take my med kit!
Oh.
Take... Oh.
You'll be okay.
You're still alive.
Right?
You'll be okay.
Um... Team?
Ryan?
Um...
Uh...
You all right down?
Oh, he's mine!
He respawned, he respawned.
I wish I could respawn.
Everybody came in and blasted me.
You see the guy in there, I see him in there.
Oh!
I wanna try the other game mode though.
Oh my god, he's right there!
Um...
He's like right next to you.
Oh, okay.
I don't think you're making it out.
Oh, wait.
Wait, you're still alive.
You're still alive.
You could do this.
Just respawn.
Yeah, nice, nice.
You gotta get your stuff back.
Oh, it kind of sucks.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, I get more about it.
watching my friend play they're close they're scaring me they're scaring me that guy's right there um maybe the camouflage does work wait huh one minute remaining what was that one of those camo decoys maybe oh my gosh yeah Take him down, CQC!
Oh!
Knife him!
Aim, doko!
He's right in front of you!
Yeah, yeah!
Knife is...
Knife and knife him!
Oh, no!
You're so close!
Oh, gosh.
I think that's it for our team.
Go, Ryan!
Oh, wait, Ryan.
Ryan, all you gotta do is get up and get to a...
Gakko, baby.
Come on, come on!
They'll get to the Gakko baby!
Come on Ryan, you can do it!
You can do it!
Just run!
Oh, there's not a round, are there?
Oh my god!
This is the worst possible situation.
Oh.
Get Fultoned.
You did so good!
Yeah, I don't think there's a respawn limit, but I don't understand why I died then.
Guys, I'm Brian.
I'm sorry for choking.
You did it!
We're all learning the game.
This is all of our first time playing.
Don't worry about it.
You did so good.
Unless we got in here.
A lot of nymphs.
Like, obviously, I recognize you.
Ocelot.
Wait.
Undress.
What are you doing?
Ocelot undress.
You're not allowed to use camo.
You were down when...
Thank you.
You were down when phase one ended so you got filtered.
Oh my god.
Two minutes remaining.
I think maybe I just don't recognize your steam names.
Where's your body?
Oh, over there.
Look at you.
Doing your thing.
What do you got?
What'd you get in there?
Whoa!
See, you need to wait on the item to pick it.
What do you mean by that?
Also, don't say see.
I'm playing the game.
I'm not reading chat.
I don't know why it didn't let me.
Ah, guys, so you say welcome back.
Thank you.
If I keep my steam names the same as everything, right?
Here.
You need to hover over it a little bit?
Is that the case?
I feel like I was on it, but...
There's a guy right there!
Maybe?
Is that a decoy?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, sometimes the decoys are crazy.
Are they...
It's a decoy!
Wait, that's kind of crazy!
Oh!
Ray trap.
Wait, that's such a good trap.
That's so awesome.
This looks wrong.
This is so wrong.
This is disturbing.
My man!
Oh, the poison gas!
Nice.
Uh-oh.
Or... Oh, neither of you guys are gonna...
Oh, nice, nice!
Oh!
Good job!
Is it just you?
This team outperformed all others during the mission.
Good job!
I congratulate.
Yeah, you did it, yeah.
You're gonna extract him.
It is time to start the mission debriefing.
Look at all of us tying for fours!
Wait!
That's awesome.
I find that your results this time were neither particularly good or bad.
Thank you.
It's a lot of fours.
Yeah, it's so spooky.
GG, fellow soldier.
It's in you too.
Ah, thank you!
Yeah.
You guys were a good team.
One of your fellow members has joined the operation.
Someone put down a Rex or a Ray or somebody.
I want to see...
Wait, what time is it?
Okay, I have an hour still.
Alright, then I'm gonna leave the room.
Let's get in another group of, another team.
Going.
The field has been confirmed.
Please get ready to deploy.
I love how they always start meeting each other.
Do photo shoot.
All right, I'm gonna make...
Please get ready to deploy.
I'm gonna show the room code.
Show the room code in a three, a two, a one, and show.
One, nine, zero, six, four, four.
Nobody wants to play with me.
One of your fellow members has joined the...
We have room for one more!
Thank you!
Love you, Minto Platonically.
Thank you, Maddox!
Thank you so much for a whole year!
Thank you!
Enjoyed being the Ocelot for a bit.
Thank you for...
Wait, we have another Ocelot!
Ocelot...
We have...
We have multiple people!
We have Shiba!
Oh my gosh, this is the best ever!
This is the...
I should have done better is what she says.
Just stand in there.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Let's do this.
I'm sorry.
Wait, you do...
You can be zero!
Wait, this is insane!
Oh my gosh, it's like a...
You know when, like, people cosplay, but, like, they don't have a full group or something?
It feels like that.
Where, like, people are just random cosplayers.
Like, stop teabagging me.
Where it's, like, can you play as Johnny?
Am I not Johnny right now?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I'm so obsessed with this.
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
Alright, let's ready up!
Ready up, everybody!
Ready up!
Zero's got the moves!
It's so funny!
Kubei!
We need you to ready up, please.
Let's...
Everybody's just kind of chilling.
It's so good.
If you play as a character that is like a costume character, don't camouflage.
It'll be against the rules.
Let's go!
Oh.
Oh, this map again.
This is kind of like Portable Ops Online back in the day because you could play as a lot of these characters in the eyes.
Oh my god!
Even and Zero got paired up together.
Alright, Vice.
Let's go.
We got this.
Wait, that's a mine right there.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, they're everywhere!
Um, I'll take this.
I got a ration.
I should probably like eat the things I get, huh?
We should probably go out this way, maybe?
Oh!
Was that you?
Uh-oh.
That wasn't you, was it?
Was that you?
Oh, that wasn't you.
I hope you had fun playing Alien Isolation.
That game is so scary.
Hello, hello!
Welcome!
Where's, uh, this?
Oh, what's that?
Wait, what is this?
Pick up item?
What is that?
Oh, I got a box!
Oh my gosh, I got a box!
Wait, there's a gun here.
I got a gun.
I got things.
I got things!
Let's go!
I got a box!
Thank you guys so much for the- I'm missing all of the donors, or not the gift and memberships, but thank you guys.
Thank you.
Oh, I can't scan the area while this is on.
Are you going this way?
You're so brave.
Why are you doing that?
You're going to go this way?
Alright, I'll go with you.
I guess we do got to get out of here, huh?
So this one is the Gakul, and again, yeah.
One minute remaining.
Whoa!
Oh, see, it'll let me pick up this one!
I don't... I don't understand why it wouldn't let me pick up the other one before.
Yeah, eat that.
I'll eat one too.
Wait, how do I eat it?
Nice.
30 seconds remaining.
Yeah, open that.
Wait, we gotta find a Gokko.
Wait.
Wait, Vice, we gotta go find the Gaku!
We're in trouble!
The current phase is nearly complete.
You must quickly make your way to the zone.
Uh-oh.
Where?
Watch out.
There's more here.
Wait, there's one over here!
Maybe?
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Wait, we're gonna lose!
It's gonna explode on me.
Phase complete.
Well today.
Please wait until the exercise is over.
I got too comfy.
No!
Oh my god, I shut up the flowers.
Oh, yeah, too much dilly-dallying.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, I know.
I want to see, like, the model for Zero, you know?
I feel like this is a rare chance.
We get to see him, like, actually running around.
and stuff dilly dally shilly i messed up i'm sorry guys i don't want to i want to like actually play i don't want to just be watching everybody all the time i'm so sorry
smhv2 we're just play butter yeah i i get i got kind of comfortable with like forgetting about the time limit i thought there'd be more time too it's like a tutorial Yeah, yeah.
Eva.
Wait!
Wait, did she just...
Did I just hear Eva go?
It is zipped down.
Let's go.
Good job.
Oh, what a voice.
Damn, you are gaming bear.
I'm gonna eat some chips.
I hope that's okay.
their veggie chips and their ghosts and bats this bear do be gaming wait you got armor on and everything oh my gosh this okay nobody saw that nobody laughed nobody saw that nobody
saw Saw what?
Yeah, nobody saw it.
I think your buddy's in here.
Yeah, your buddy's in here.
30 seconds remaining.
What is that?
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
I think that's Eva.
No?
Wait, why did...
Why did you have such a cute voice then?
Phase 3.
Oh my gosh, it's just, it's just warm.
Seeing Zero do the CQ.
Look at his hands.
Is that Zero's voice?
Wait a second.
Do you guys hear that?
What?
Was there a mistake?
I want to, I want to hear.
Whoa!
Someone CQC him so I can hear his voice.
Oh, my vision.
You got this?
Be aggressive, be aggressive?
What does that do?
You hear that right?
I think Zero has a sexy voice.
Yeah!
Can you dive again, Mark?
Why is your voice...
Why is he so sexy?
Die for me, Mark.
Die for me.
What is...
Oh, whoop.
Are they coming in?
Is this the last phase?
How many phases are there?
Yeah, Mark is like, I'm not listening to you, VTuber.
I'm playing this game and I'm gonna win.
Oh my god!
They're
like so insane.
Oh my gosh.
Mark doesn't even watch the streams.
Somehow he just guessed the code.
He's just like insane.
What are you doing?
He's so locked in.
No way.
I think he still wins though, right?
Oh no, this is the final phase.
Oh my gosh, this is so awkward.
Run away, my girlfriend?
Girlfriend Zero?
He's here for the love of the game.
It's just these two, right?
Oh my god.
He killed tax fraud!
How many people are left?
Oh, wow.
Wait, Q-Bay, where?
Wait.
How are we in the final phase, but there's...
still so many people.
What?
Is there a glitch?
I thought it was supposed to... Wait.
Eh?
How are there so many people still?
There were other Gakko.
I guess that's fair.
Ooh.
Two minutes remaining.
I'm still having fun watching, though.
I'm like learning more the game by watching everybody else.
Tax fraud!
Oh, uh-oh.
Did you say that?
Sparky, did you say that?
Oh, they're gone.
Sparky, Sparky, be careful.
Oh!
Oh, the guy, like, right next to you.
What about the guy right there?
Who's pretending to be dead.
He's like, I can pretend to be a decoy.
CQC him!
This is gonna be insane.
There's so many people.
Oh.
Hexrod, did I just hear your stomach?
Oh, it's because you died.
The wisps have seized the means of streaming.
Hugo, welcome!
Oh, hello, I should have.
I'm hungry too.
That's why I'm eating.
It's absolute insanity!
It's insane!
Oh my god.
Kick him while he's down.
Oh, kick him while he's down.
Kick them both while they're down.
Oh my god!
Is anyone on a team anymore?
Stealth game, by the way.
Not this version.
Foxhunt isn't meant to be stealth.
Grenade!
Everybody dies!
Mark, you got this?
Oh, I don't think Mark got this.
Her voice is so cute.
Cute, saluting each other.
Wow, good job.
Oh, you can just keep spamming.
Congrats, that's funny.
It is time to start the mission debriefing.
Um, well, fourth?
Um, well, there were three?
It was, uh, tied for fourth.
I did fairly well.
See, she likes me.
What is this mode?
This is the new Fox Hunt mode.
It just was released an hour ago.
4-4-4, baby.
Yay!
One of your fellow members has joined the operation.
I should have done better.
Why do you have a cute voice?
Why?
How do you?
How?
Tell me.
Tell me now, Mark.
Tell me now.
How?
I should have done better.
Good luck out there.
I'm sorry.
Good look out there.
Good luck out there.
Thank you guys.
It's so goofy.
It's actually just so stinking goofy!
Good game y'all.
It's a hell of a fun time.
Thanks for hosting me, dog.
Yeah!
What an exit.
It was so funny.
Please get ready to deploy.
Alright, another custom.
Better than Titanic.
It was like the best response that I could have asked for when I was interrogating him.
Mark here.
Mark!
Okay, you can change your voice in your survival room.
I can?
Wait.
mission settings?
Oh, look at this!
Wait!
Ghost!
We need to go to the ghost... Oh, wait, we did go to Ghost Garrison.
Oh, wow.
Wait, we haven't gone to Secret Garden.
Let's do that one.
I'm guessing...
Let's do... I'll set it as a capture.
Hugo, thank you!
Welcome back.
It was an honor serving with you, Minky.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Good luck out there, TTT.
I was an Eva, I have no idea why I had a manly voice.
No, apparently...
Kojima is gone.
Apparently you have to change it.
Please get ready to deploy.
But...
Oh, it might go to survival room.
Please complete any necessary customizations.
Oh, here!
Oh!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
I have none.
But look how many there are!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Radio presets.
Oh, look how many!
Wait.
Copy that.
Let's see if I...
Whoa!
Oh, wow!
Voice settings.
Okay, I see it too.
Oh my gosh!
There's so much to unlock!
Look!
You ready?
That was amazing!
I could be Robin!
Is it Robin waiting?
It kind of sounds like him.
I can't tell actually.
I look forward to fighting by your side.
Until next time.
Good work.
That was amazing.
luck out there thank you please accept my apology whoa he sounds so give me backup give me backup holy voice settings batman it's no good let's kick some butt let's kick some butt which one sounds like me good job today nice keep up the fight wow i like this one thank you i'm sorry I need some cover fire copy that copy that's not gonna work let's kick some butt farewell you thought well out there oh that was amazing oh that was amazing keep up the fight type c minus one thank you the way he says please oh golly that that's not gonna happen farewell it doesn't you can only go plus one you can't go any higher how high yeah only just plus one or minus one
bad to you you fought well today i'll do this one there's so many to unlock no way AT camel.
You can even unlock AT camel.
Wow.
So cool.
Fourth,
fourth, fourth.
I'm so consistent.
Okay.
Did I make the room?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna open up the room.
And if you played already before, I'm sorry please don't join again and this might be last game because I do have a meeting in 30 minutes so wait it is 30 minutes right hold on
I'm double checking hot dog
yes yes meow meow do you think wait do you think that there might be some of the well Do you think some of the voice clips from Peace Walker are in this?
I might.
I might freak.
Meow.
Okay.
Uh, displaying the room ID in...
A three.
A two.
A one.
And boom!
512570.
One of your fellow members has joined the...
One of your...
Your fellow members has joined the operation.
One of your fellow members has joined the operation.
Wait, do I see paramedic?
Oh my god, paramedic!
I said I!
Wait, you have a different soldier outfit.
Oh my gosh!
Hi.
Don't leave me hanging.
Ha-ha-ha!
Don't leave me...
You know we left duck hanging and what happened to him?
We left duck hanging.
Oh, wow.
Oh yeah.
Everybody is so aroused.
Rocky!
Thank you so much for the Rita rags!
Hello, everybody.
Hi!
We're playing Metal Gear, Fox Hunt.
Wow.
Wait, how do I get out of this?
Wait, I can't get out of it.
Oh wait, I can't...
Oh, there we go.
What is that one?
The little cowering one is so cute.
Oh, this one.
Ah, kawaii!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Dwargo, thank you so much for the five gifted!
Rest in glitch phase, thank you for the gifted!
What was I gonna do?
I give this...
Oh, come on, I didn't get to do my emo.
And J-Go's, thank you so much.
Now I will thank you.
Do my eyes deceive me or am I paired with us?
We, Ashen, we, Ashen, we're paired.
We're buddies and you're us a lot.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, let's start the game.
Ready up, everybody!
Ready up, ready up!
I look forward to fighting by your side.
This is the perfect end of where I get to fight with us a lot.
I'm like...
Wait, this is so cool!
Wait!
Oh!
And this one is the Kedotan one.
We haven't tried this one.
Okay.
I'm calm, I'm cool, and I'm collected.
I can't let him show- I can't- I can't let him see how excited I am.
My dream came true.
Mission.
Survival capture.
How do I screenshot?
Okay.
No!
I don't know if I got him in time or not.
The mission is about to begin.
Wait,
there's a button right here!
Um, I got him.
How many do we need?
Wait, that one is...
That one's special color.
Oh my gosh, I got a cool decal!
Yeah, I know, I'm scared.
Did you get a gun yet or anything?
Are you okay?
Oh my god.
Oh, hi.
It's me.
I'm Leo.
We both have one.
I guess?
Two minutes remaining.
No sign of the enemy.
Cool.
Wait.
Um, there's a sign of the enemy.
He's like right behind us.
I got somebody!
I got
you!
I got you!
I'll save you!
Oh my god, wait.
Oh there you are.
You can't leave me!
You can't!
Wait, I have your things!
Wait, I took some of your stuff!
Oh, uh...
Ow!
Ouchie out!
Yeah, thank you!
Oh, out, Jailch.
I think you hit me.
Good job, team.
Wait, somebody else over here.
I'm waiting for you.
Ouch!
Your buddy has been badly and your buddy is confirmed dead.
No!
Ouch!
Oh, I got him.
Oh, shoot!
Ouch!
Wait, wait, hold on!
Hold on!
Buddy!
Buddy, buddy, buddy.
Wait, no, I'm gonna...
Wait, no!
Please retrieve your equipment.
Phase complete.
I guess this is the end.
You fought Braveheart today.
I was doing so well.
Phase 2.
Well, this is kind of...
This is kind of freaky.
Seeing paramedic down like that is kind of really scary.
Oh man, is this a...
This seems like a much smaller...
Oh, smaller map.
Look at you!
You are a squirrel!
You're a squirrel!
That's so cute.
I got two kills!
I got two kills.
Is it...
Shin-chi?
Welcome to- welcome back to membership!
Thank you!
Sorry if I said your name wrong.
About a pronunciation surprise.
How many do you need to survive?
There's one just...
There's one just chillin' here.
Are you watching that guy?
That's not your buddy.
Kill him!
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
Scout!
...
Is this shotguns only or something?
I know, right?
Well, no, I don't think so because...
There was definitely somebody who...
Definitely somebody who was shooting faster than I was.
Oh my gosh.
Astrea, I didn't even see you.
That was like some really good camera.
Holy paramedic!
One minute remaining.
Oh my gosh, paramedic.
Are you okay?
So beat up.
Oh.
This is a side of paramedic we'll never see again.
It's kind of insane.
Lord of men here I flunked out, but Luca Dan is my buddy.
Thanks for playing me, though.
Thank you!
I thought it was you.
Thank you.
30 seconds remaining.
30 seconds.
Oh, you got two.
You got... Oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Wait, your buddy's down!
Sorry, I couldn't keep Oslo.
No!
Ash and you were great!
Thank you for being my buddy.
This is a really small map.
So it's like very tough.
People are just on top of you.
Phase complete.
Teeny time.
Target's place too.
Oh, you're red on top of it.
Wackwackwackwack.
I don't know what kind of fox we're hunting, but it's got to be good if Big Minky is here observing the fight.
I put up a...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
I feel like I put up my own fight as well.
Damn.
You gonna take his stuff?
Wait.
Oh.
It's just the two of you.
Wait, when did...
When did we lose...
Paramedic?
Oh.
There's so much stuff here.
Who died?
Nice.
If they keep adding onto Fox Hunt, it would be really cool.
I would like to see...
Like, you know, more modes.
It's one-on-one.
But they both have two.
Yeah, both can survive, no?
Um, I guess you would have to kill the other person.
It might go into, like, overtime, you know.
Yeah, new maps and stuff, too.
That looks like a trap, no?
leaves oh my gosh array don't you want to just go look at it i have hearts coming out of my head right now one minute remaining they're looking for each other yeah they're looking for each other it's tense it's tense
oh Oh my god, wait.
I think Luca just won this.
I think Luca Dan just won this.
Forget dirty Dan.
It's Luca Dan.
Uh-oh.
Astrea.
Oh.
Get him, get him, get him.
Oh, that's just some rocks.
Ah, so close.
Yeah!
One day I'll see.
This team outperformed all others during...
There you are, Florida man!
It is time to start the mission debriefing.
I'm so consistent.
Was it really phase one?
Oh, okay.
I meant always four.
You did fairly well.
She said I did well, everybody.
I did well.
Uh, that first phase in that map was crazy.
Because there's so many people.
And such a small map.
We, but you know, we got to see all of them, I guess?
Hmm.
One of your fellow members has joined the...
One of your fellow members has joined the operation.
Her hair looks so silky.
Good luck out there.
Oh.
Thank you.
Ashen, we did well.
Good job.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Keep up the fight.
Thank you.
Good luck out there.
I can't do that.
I'm sorry.
Oh, look at you guys.
You're so cute.
I can't with the kawaii pose.
It's so good.
Look at it.
Good work.
Let's do this.
It is so cursed.
I don't think I could...
I don't think I can...
I don't think I can play.
It's so funny watching the emotes.
Kawaii!
Wait, I wanna dance too.
Let's have a dance party!
Dance party!
Oh, everybody coming over!
I'm a dance party!
Dance a party!
Come on, come on!
Dance party!
Let's kick some butt!
Let's do this!
Thank you.
Thank you for dancing with me, everyone.
Thanks for playing with me!
My game crashed right when loading back into the lobby.
Oh no!
Oh, look!
Everyone's dance party!
Dance party!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah- That's so good.
Why is like, Ocelot's neck bend like that?
This is so funny.
Wait.
Oh!
Grenade!
Nice!
Thank you!
Oh!
And to all of you.
Thank you for playing with me, for watching.
I would like to play again.
Maybe we'll do more Fox Hunt in the future.
but also maybe as like a member streams and things like that too so um i gotta play i gotta play games so i can um what's the word so i can uh get experience that's earlier what you can do for us the honest answer is please keep being your amazing lovable self and take some wispy hugs and head pads and be happy
Thank you for Superfund, MGS4T, or Foxhunt, and Shenanigans.
Thank you!
Thanks for the ping.
No, well, thank you so much for the 20!
Thank you.
I got Ocelot in the Gotcha Pool.
It's Gotcha?
That would explain what...
Wait.
Oh gosh, I wonder what else then.
What the...
I only have 10 minutes, so I don't think I have time.
But...
The field has been confirmed.
Please get ready to deploy.
Thank you, thank you.
I guess, what is it?
The reward package?
Is that how you do the gotcha?
It's gotcha.
But I think you have to get the experience, no?
Yeah, okay.
It does not seem paid to win.
You get 100 tokens per level up.
That gives you three to seven pulls per request.
Oh, nice.
One day I will play a game with Minto.
Rusty Glitchface!
Gotta go Roadrunner cartoons, my RSP!
Oh!
Roadrunner cartoons!
Yeah, it's not pay to win.
You just gotta play the game.
So that's good.
It's just gotcha for skins, you guys.
Don't get it twisted.
Helping enable my Oshi's gotcha addiction.
Don't, don't, don't it!
It's not actual money.
Okay.
Well, thank you, guys.
We can play this weekly if you want.
You know what, actually, I've been playing so much.
Look, you can see it.
In the middle, you can see the boss.
But a game I've been playing so much is actually a clover pit.
Wait, how'd you know?
This bar, how did you know?
I play so much Clover Pit.
When I have free time, I'm usually playing Clover Pit.
Only once have I gotten further than I did on stream.
Level up finds.
Oh my gosh, Fukuoka.
Thank you.
Let's go gambling.
That's really, really hard for me to not stream it.
Did you escape?
No.
Oh, I told it.
I told you guys?
Oh.
I did!
Wow.
Oh yeah, I told you guys.
Ah.
You said you'd play Clover Pit off stream.
We saw the unlocks.
How?
Oh, in the 3D stream.
That's right.
I did show.
I forgot that stream is like out of my brain because it was such a mess.
But yeah.
I will see you guys later.
Tomorrow is a very spooky stream.
We go back to spooky.
We only have two more days left of spookiness.
Well, I guess Silent Hill is also on Saturday.
Two days left of Halloween spookiness.
Tomorrow we will go on a tour.
You guys remember Gabe?
He gave us a tour last time of the USS Hornet.
Well, this time it will be all the ghost stories of the USS Hornet.
So maybe we'll get a ghost on camera.
I'll make sure you guys get my best angle.
I'll see you guys next Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, thank you
Thank you, thank you Thank you, Carl
I was just thinking yesterday I was laying on the floor I was thinking But you guys know Actually, yeah, it was something to tell you guys Because I'll be moving Sometime next year Because I plan on moving, I've actually I plan on moving quite far actually So I've been making preparations to get rid of my patchy slot.
But I think wherever I end up, I will probably buy a new one.
I'll get another one.
Yeah.
But don't worry, it will come back to me.
They're actually quite easy to obtain, it seems.
So.
Yeah, but...
Yeah, I think I think it's I think I think it cannot come with me So sad Oh, yeah Is the shipping a hassle a great hassle this thing is extremely heavy you guys don't know The struggle it was to even put it into my room like I could barely even get it through the front door So...
Patchy slap buns...
No!
No, no, no.
I called dims.
Are you changing time zones?
Yes!
But I still plan to have my streams at similar times.
But also, I won't be moving for quite some months, so...
Don't need to worry about it.